how well do the match participants  remember their iconic shots how many  seconds did it take from oh God  a lifetime it's I think it's still  rolling what was the call on TV in your  life area same thing like that  [Applause]  how long did the ball sit on the rim of  the cup before too long way too long two  seconds how far away was your second  shot pull out it was like  137 yards how many times did you look up  and down before you actually swung  three what club were you using seven  iron how many yards was the hole I want  to say it was 217 but I don't know what  the adjustment was with the downhill how  many times did you look up while  practicing your swing before final and  hitting uh two what was your score  before the whole uh I made birdie I  think to get to 900 so I was eight under  before that what club were you using I  was hitting a 60 degree out of the  bunker